[Music]
in snowflake generation news alright how
that happened you sensitive I think I'm
one of them what's this no plate
generation snowflakes of people get
offended by everything there's no
special and they're fragile and you have
to take care of them is that what that
means I just made that up
no they just use that to refer to people
that get offended by everything I like
super sensitive is it's fragile they
melt quickly they're soft
submitted by everybody clap your hands
that's a cupid shuffle yeah I didn't get
everybody clap your hands that's a
wedding song Millennials are outraged
after a baseball team advertises
millennial night at a local ball they
want to celebrate Millennials [ __ ]
pissed about it I don't get it yeah
Millennials can [ __ ] be outraged
about everything yeah anything it's so
sad what do you mean brown dirt night I
just learned that like our generation
because we're older than Millennials
right but we're still considered
millennial 82 to like 2000 something see
I heard that too but then someone else
says that like since we were like worn
back we're in the middle with someone
called us as ill any old ours anyway
Neil's home sitting like that I don't
know man I like that one we were there
for the crossover of when everything
changed right now I feel like we're in
the middle because within our group we
have snowflake ass [ __ ] mm-hmm and
then we have people that are just like
so old-school mm-hmm
you sound like a senior citizen and
you're only 32 yeah so this story takes
place in Alabama Alabama League baseball
team called the Montgomery biscuits
that's how they need to do [ __ ] like
this their minor league any other wack
ass names but magic mascots giant
biscuits is running around Oh with the
butter on it yeah
it's butter on it for real by the way
tweeted this out it says millennial
night free stuff participation ribbon
selfie stations napping area millennial
night [ __ ] is welcome the actual tweet
itself it says want free things without
doing much work well you're in luck
shade walk stadia will be Millennial
friendly on Saturday July 21st with a
participation ribbon giveaway just for
showing up napping in selfie stations
along with lots of avocados that's so
buddy I kind of like the nappy stuff I
can't get offended about that I like
napping stations - I mean I love naps
that is funny the [ __ ] basket
o butter - we aren't those eyes
copyrighted - Cookie Monster baby she
owns only Cookie Monster has the
cross-eyed really got was a crackhead
looks like that he's not - cos I've I
think that guy's those are copyrighted
eyes that's hilarious I think everything
about that is super funny I think so -
you let go you're offended no I go oh
you got on yeah you got offended that
means you're their market you're their
target then talking about you you
[ __ ] snowflake you're doing
everything they expected you didn't they
win you lose that's so funny you should
have gone and then like take advantage
of avocado sit pre [ __ ] I'm there yes so
we do a lot of these types of like
promotional things every time and so
they have like you know veteran night or
whatever night and so now they were just
thinking like oh you know just have a
little fun with it yeah millennion oh
because they're saying that 80% of the
people that put this together they're
all Millennials themselves yeah if
anything it's it's just they're making
fun of any fun of the stereotype yeah
that's dope it does sound like a low
blow though when it's like do you want
to get free [ __ ] for doing nothing at
all that does sound like that like they
are trying to like hit you where it
hurts but that's also like if you are
trying to that's the perfect place to go
but no one thinks of themselves as a
scumbag though you know what I mean so
that's like the ones that are the
snowflakes are like oh why would you
assume that there's not please think
that there were they are working hard
yeah yeah yeah that's why they are
getting offense they think sitting for
eight hours is actually doing work two
jobs yeah so then they ended up tweeting
this again
they were like offended
feel free to fight your battles IRL and
visit us at River Watch they do draw
them in any Millennials that actually
come by during office hours before next
Saturday and submits a valid complaint
in person so our millennial night do you
think you may get a free ticket or two I
love their marketing it's bugging
awesome that is amazing their PR like if
you come and sit in our seats and buy
our corn dog then fine we'll listen to
you
so are there people in the comments like
writing paragraphs and [ __ ] yeah I love
that [ __ ] you know
so before I used to be irritated like
why there's so many people complaining
but now with my new brain you just gotta
see it with different goggles man put
these on Bo it's gonna be hilarious oh
my god I can't believe people like this
exist yeah it's [ __ ] hilarious that's
facts because I used to be mad about how
many stupid people were in the world yes
and then I realized it's not their fault
that we're smarter than them it's not
stupid people's fault that we're better
you know I'm saying so you can't be mad
at them for being inferior people you
feel yeah yeah yeah we are cursed to be
better yeah we have to live with dumbass
people so once you look at that you
don't get mad anymore you feel bad for
them hey I need to elevate myself wow
you know I don't feel bad I'm just like
I'm looking at this so wrong I have to
put on my comedy Cobb they're all
comedians you know to me like it's like
look at this person and then the type of
person that writes that kind of [ __ ]
right I start lurking I click on their
page oh this is who you are I start
writing my own story I know what's going
on you got marital problems and you're
taking that [ __ ] out on politics this is
what's happening no I use in the same
[ __ ] whenever people would talk to you
to my comments before getting mad I'd be
like
wait for this person to be this angry in
life to go out of their way to write
this whole Ashe comment about a [ __ ]
stupid as YouTube video I did there they
have internal life problems I they
probably they didn't get hugged as a
baby you know I'm saying their parents
didn't change their diapers and [ __ ]
they're just bitter at the world itself
like damn I feel sorry for you my child
you know I'm saying you didn't get that
love that I have in my life so feel free
if this makes you feel better
writing [ __ ] two paragraphs about my
like two minute youtube video makes you
feel better about life go ahead do you
think sometimes it's entertaining though
when trolls get up in the mix and people
take them seriously and they'll just be
arguing about the orderin or something
[ __ ] irrelevant as hell and I'm just
like holies people are heated about
degree in acts like some of these tweets
said my favorite part about this is the
participation ribbon bit which you see a
lot from old people you realize it was
the older generation Millennials parents
who created those ribbons right you're
blaming young people for something you
invent it and hand it out that's very
true though yeah it's funny because
Millennials do get the blame of like why
are you so entitled it's like [ __ ] the
older folks are the ones that created
the program to give everybody a [ __ ]
ribbon give everybody a consolation
prize like the kids didn't [ __ ] bring
that up yo some [ __ ] though you know
yeah you feel a beat but when I used to
get those I hated those how's that why
am I getting one that just this
participation that me aren't under do
something yeah man we're rewarding yeah
look if everybody's a winner nobody's a
winner only do you guys have like
elementary school orleans-based
elementary school would be like for like
jump roping or like the balance beam I
some [ __ ] ass event so we got
elementary school Olympics and then if I
didn't win one of the events and I got
like a participation medal like me and
the other twenty kids like I didn't feel
like I earned anything you know I just
[ __ ] threw that [ __ ] away I said I
wanted the jump rope one or the balance
beam one man I was so stupid I was happy
with anything I'll [ __ ] wait like oh
I wish we get I get perfect attendance
this time it's like I [ __ ] missed
like a week of school I know this yeah
but I'm thinking it's a lot of like
maybe they forgot about it maybe maybe
I'll get the certificate this month this
i'ma get it ya know people don't realize
that like losing I mean some people
realize but losing is it motivates you
you don't saying because you want to be
better like you want to do better so you
can actually like be on this level that
you didn't get to before you don't
saying that's why you can't give
everybody ribbons for everything you
don't get better from winning yeah you
don't there's not really much self
reflection from winning that's true
because I remember if you did your
homework and you did it good you would
get a scratch-and-sniff sticker and if
it was like medium level then you would
get like a gold star and then a you'll
get a silver star and then you'll just
get an X if you don't do your homework
or whatever so then I [ __ ] work my
ass off to get the scratch-and-sniff cuz
that was my [ __ ] man I would [ __ ] all
day long and was it wherever the [ __ ]
smell do it will only last like a day
but what what you remember the smell
though yeah purple was my favorite see
stayed with him for life yep
root beer was weird as [ __ ] maker is
black why the [ __ ] would anyone want
that it's like burnt tired of humor
scratch-and-sniff was kind of licorice
she was I got weird yeah yeah I always
liked the pink color ones and all that
[ __ ] man
that was like a crack fiend for smells I
was like give me that [ __ ] yeah I like
the a snozzberry ones what snozzberry
snozzberries taste like snozzberries
yeah yes we're people they taste like
snozzberries damnit that's you guys his
age
no oh well that was in there [ __ ] I just
remember the kid [ __ ] turn into a
bulimia [ __ ] and then the other kid
[ __ ] fell in the river and when he
fell in the river
I was like that's right you [ __ ]
uh-huh augustus Gloop you can pursue the
plan you get when you gobble down sweets
eating as much as an elephant eats
eat up justjust Agusta which is pretty
funny and then so it's funny too because
a lot of the players are Millennials too
and then the players themselves in there
being interviewed they were like they
just have tougher skin if they're really
relaxed
they just the Joe yeah [ __ ] oh dude
it's just a job what's gonna happen if
the majority is like this cuz I don't
really know if this is really the
reflection of the majority it might be a
loud minority hmm maybe yeah well I mean
there are a lot of people that were just
laughing like this is just a joke like
no it definitely was balanced out but
it's just the fact that Millennials were
being outraged making this headline it's
[ __ ] hilarious dude I'm gonna find a
to retweet it right now I'm on a tiny
Armada Falco's
[Music]